we have 7 times 10 to the 5th over 2
times 10 to the negative 2 times 2 point
5 times 10 to the 9th
so let's try to simplify this a little
bit and I'll start off by trying to
simplify this denominator here so the
numerator is just 7 times 10 to the 5th
and the denominator I just have a bunch
of numbers that are being multiplied
times each other so I can do it in any
order so let me swap the order so I'm
going to do it to it's over 2 times 2.5
2.5 times 10 to the negative 2 times 10
to the negative 2 times 10 to the 9th
times 10 to the ninth and this is going
to be equal to so the numerator I
haven't changed yet 7 times 10 to the
fifth over over and here in the
denominator 2 times let me do this in a
new color now 2 times 2 point 5 is 5 and
then 10 to the negative 2 times 10 to
the 9th when you multiply two numbers
that are being raised to exponents and
they have the exact same base so it's 10
to the negative 2 times 10 to the
negative 9 we can add the exponents so
this is going to be 10 to the 9 minus 2
or 10 to the 7th so times 10 to the 7th
and now we can view this as being equal
to this is being equal to 7 over 5 7
over 5 times 10 to the fifth over 10 to
the 7th times 10 to the 5th 10 to the
fifth over 10 to the seventh 10 to the
seventh we do then that orange color to
keep track of the colors 10 to the
seventh now what is 7 divided by 5 7
divided by 5 is equal to C it's one and
two fifths or one point four so I'll
just write it as one point four and then
10 to the fifth divided by 10 to the
seventh so that's going to be the same
thing as and there's two ways to view
this you could view this as 10 to the
fifth times 10 to the negative 7 you add
the exponents you get 10 to the negative
2 or you say hey look I have I'm
dividing this by this we have the same
base we can subtract exponent so it's
going to be 10 to the 5 minus
which is 10 to the negative 2 so this
part right over here is going to
simplify 2 times 10 to the negative 2
now are we done have we written what we
have here in scientific notation it
looks like we have this value right over
here is greater than or equal to 1 but
it is less than it is less than or it's
less than or equal to 9 it's a digit
between 1 and 9 including one at 9 and
we have and it's being multiplied by 10
to some power so this is it looks like
we're done this simplified to one point
four times 10 to the negative 2